bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans votre caddie ce matin actualité
oblige avec eux bernard bûcher bonjour
bonjour monsieur car oui bonjour à tous
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
et de répondre à nos questions ce matin
vous êtes médecin martiniquais mais
surtout alors vous intervenez ici vous
êtes rattaché notamment hostis le
service territorial d'incendié et de
secours
mais vous êtes aussi professeur de santé
publique internationale et vous
professez notamment à l'université
américaine george washington et c'est
bien pour ça que vous êtes ce matin
présent avec nous dans ce studio parce
qu'avec vous il sera notamment question
du changement de présidence des états
unis
alors on se souvient docteur bernard
bûcher il ya douze ans pas dans ce
studio mais dans l'ancien clairière le
studio albert auguste nous étions dans
le même exercice
concernant la première élection de
barack obama
alors vous qui travaillez entre les deux
pays
beaucoup d'eau a coulé sous les ponts
depuis sa première élection de barack
obama et comment avez vous vu vécu cet
exercice du pouvoir de ces quatre
dernières années avec donald trump un
exercice du pouvoir aux états unis à
nulle autre pareille
oui déjà ça nous rajeunit non les faits
ça a été quelque chose d'assez
intéressant puisque ça a été un retour
de balancier barack obama si vous voulez
avait dirigé les états unis de manière
très européenne on va dire et en
s'appuyant géographiquement sur les
côtes américaines qui sont les plus
progressive un du site américain mais
est il avait peut-être négligé le centre
et c'est le centre il s'est rappelé à
lui je veux devenir le centre
géographique des états unis qui s'est
rappelé à lui en élisant trompe et ou
démocrates surtout hillary clinton a
finalement perdu alors qu'elles avaient
elles étaient majoritaires en voix mais
bon le système électoral avait été
finalement donald trump avait accédé au
pouvoir est en effet bon ça a été un
exercice intéressant qui au départ était
pas mal on va lire un puisque axé sur
l'économie et sur le redémarrage des
économies rééquilibrage alors il déjà
vous vous ne rajoutez pas tout en bloc
de ce qu'a pu faire donald trump et
finalement son administration parce
qu'on focalise beaucoup sur lui mais
n'ont pas totalement déjà le secrétaire
d'état a choisi de joe banane acp
approuver l'atttitude qu'il a eue de
rééquilibrer face à la chine donc on
peut dire qu'il ya des choses qui
étaient plus calmes attentes et puis il
le dira pages liées à la situation du
cog hill effectivement à partir de là il
ya une fuite en avant
alors on va y venir à la crise sanitaire
que vivent encore les etats-unis 1-1 et
de manière assez intense mais certains
observateurs beaucoup et notamment la
presse étasunienne elle même n'est pas
tendre avec la présidence trump est dit
qu ils laissent un champ de ruines quoi
que les états unis d'amérique bien ils
sont plus tout aussi unique
qu'auparavant 1
et c'est bien là tout le challenge qui
se présente à joe biden mais surtout
aussi à sa vice présidente on va en
parler c'est à dire pacifié et tenter de
réunir un tant soit peu un peu plus les
états unis que dites-vous de kamala
harris qui on le rappelle a des origines
indiennes mais aussi jamaïcaine son père
était jamaïcain et a étudié aux états
unis c'est exact c'est à dire que c'est
le rôle central donné à kamala harris
qui à mon avis le rôle donné à la femme
américaine parce que on est dans une
période de reconstruction
bien évidemment là il ya eu
à nouveau une crise dans mutations comme
ça arrive souvent comme pendant la
guerre de sécession pendant ces périodes
comme la deuxième guerre mondiale
et là il ya un chantier qui s'ouvre
devant lui un petit peu comme delano
roosevelt franklin d air juste après la
deuxième guerre mondiale
pour cela cette reconstruction qui passe
par un problème de valeurs un problème
de peur se construit d'abord à
l'intérieur des maisons et c'est pour
cela que la femme est extrêmement
importante et vous parlez de kamala
harris mais l'équipe de ben laden est
extrêmement féminisé avec des fameuses
et qui traîne une rétro coup de
diversité voilà comment devant benoît
est très positif de d'obama parce que ce
sont des femmes qui ont été à peu près
au lycée quand barack obama est devenu
président et qui ont un modèle son
modèle celui de michel et qui n'ont plus
peur et qui par conséquent aux
participer enfin pour créer la diversité
américaine et vous dit michel vous
faites référence à michelle obama la
première dame des etats-unis pendant
huit ans les pousses de barack obama
vous voyez un avenir à kamal à lui si
vous pensez que voilà parce qu'il ya eu
barack obama a été le premier président
noir aux états unis certains disent
qu'elle est bien partie peut-être pour
au moins tenter peut-être d'être la
première présidente
oui c'est là que ça va se jouer il faut
à mon avec elles apprennent beaucoup aux
côtés de bad dangerous chez de la
politique et qui est un homme
spécialiste du gouvernement au centre un
homme qui va justement reprendre une
valeur américaine de l' équilibre entre
entre les deux parties donc si kamala
harris qui a déjà une certaine appétence
pour cela puisque les sénatrice de
californie et beaucoup de choses comme
ça se joue au sénat si elle apprend de
son mentor quelques centres et là tout à
fait la possibilité un jour je pense
devenir la première femme présidente des
états unis docteur bernard bûcher on le
rappelle donc vous êtes vous même vous
intervenez en tant que médecin donc aux
états unis vous êtes professeur de santé
publique internationale à l'université
américaine george washington vous avez
collaboré avec l'administration barack
obama notamment pour l'obamacare vous
êtes un de ceux qui avaient collaboré à
sa vraie à ça les etats-unis qui sont
plus que jamais dans la dans la crise du
coronavirus
le 12 janvier dernier on parlait de 4500
morts il y avait c'est un record qui a
eu par par jour pendant une seule
journée voilà un record donc le
précédent record a été battu
plus de 235 mille nouvelles
contaminations
voilà 4470 morts avaient été enregistrés
le 12 janvier
les autorités fédérales ont décidé que
tous les voyageurs souhaitant se rendre
aux états unis par avion allait devoir
désormais présentée à partir du 26
janvier donc c'est dans quelques jours
un test négatif au coville 19 afin
d'être autorisé à voyager tests qui
devraient être réalisées dans les trois
jours précédant le départ pour les etats
unis ont dit vous puisque vous même
on s'en souvient et on va faire une
transition pour chez nous lors de lors
de la première crise du premier
confinement ici en martinique vous même
en tant que médecin vous appeliez à
prendre des mesures plus strictes
concernant les entrées sur le territoire
donc finalement c'est une première
mesure assez symbolique mais utile pour
la démonstration by john harris
absolument il faut absolument le faire
et c'est aussi une harmonisation de ce
qui se passe entre les pays aussi vous
savez que des problèmes fondamentaux
c'est le problème des variants qui ne
manque pas d'arriver vu la nature même
de ce virus et la nature des coronavirus
de varier ainsi hélas les gens parlent
beaucoup du variant anglais mais aussi
le variant brésilien qui envahit
injurieux terminer enfin mobile apparent
l'apparition depuis peu de temps ne
variant californien ce matin je disais
un article très intéressant là dessus et
qui peut poser problème donc à une
course poursuite et c'est pour ça que
les états unis cherchent à vacciner au
maximum parce qu'ils n'ont pas le choix
et a vraiment une course poursuite pour
éviter une explosion à l'intérieur du
territoire puisque ça a été ça l'échec
fondamental de l'administration trump et
donc vous comment dire et comment
appréciez vous les nouvelles
restrictions
d'entrée par contre en martinique y
compris pour ceux qui viennent de
l'hexagone
enfin bon voilà qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous savez en tant que médecin
oui je ne suis pas sûr du caractère
pratique de cette chose là parce que
compte tenu des règles juridiques imposé
par les par la constitution française et
n'est pas évident qu'une certaine soit
facile à vérifier et à octobre à faire
sur le sol martiniquais j'appellerais
plutôt à une utilisation des outils de
biologie moléculaire que nous avons pour
faire de l'épidémiologie moléculaire il
s'agit à mon avis de vérifier
régulièrement
l'entrée de ces virus dans la population
martiniquaise afin de pouvoir parer au
plus pressé
je pense que c'est là surtout que les
choses vont se jouer là
la mise en oeuvre du testing massif
comme on dit qui est pas encore vraiment
efficient ici un tel qu'il est fait il
est peut être efficace mais enfin il
n'est pas encore fait me semble-t-il de
manière très très large
est-ce que là aussi il ya peut-être un
braque et un coup de braquet a donné qu
est ce que vous préconisez de ce point
de vue la macif certainement pas mais il
ya des méthodes vous savez de prise
d'échantillons bon vent dans les cheveux
et puis on peut adapter également au
niveau économique des jauges il ya un
travail excellent travail qui a été fait
par les corses sur la modélisation des
flux notamment touristiques et tout ça
s'adapte on ne prend pas vous savez des
mesures qui sont prises comme ça il faut
absolument pouvoir les suivre et les
adapter donc c'est ça qu'il faut de
méthodologie et s'est arrêté de le faire
ou au coup par coup comme ça un petit
peu au feeling comme on dit les états
unis c'est d'ailleurs ce que fait le
gouvernement baden maintenance états
unis un criant un groupe d'experts qui à
partir de la maison blanche va piloter
les choses et aider le président à
piloter les choses ouais dernière
question ici aussi on s'interroge parce
que évidemment on sait que c'est dans
les endroits où se regroupent les
les personnes les êtres humains que la
charge virale évidemment ce fait la plus
importante concernant le carnaval vous
qui êtes justement spécialistes en santé
publique etc
qu'est ce que vous en pensez est ce
qu'il faut faire un carnaval adapté
évidemment en prenant le maximum de
précautions possibles
ou est-ce qu'il faut carrément oublié
non il faut pour le monde adapté en
prenant un maximum de de précaution mais
vous savez je pense que cela faire a été
mal vécue parce que peut-être certaines
mesures ont été trop drastiques et
peut-être pas nécessaire autour de noël
jour de l'an donc je pense que
effectivement s'il ya un mauvais
ressenti de cela et avant tout peut-être
un dialogue une explication claire de la
politique doit être fait en liaison avec
la population de manière à ce que la
population par elles mêmes prennent en
main sa santé reste 30 secondes docteur
bernard bûcher
vous étiez aux états unis il n'y a pas
très longtemps ça fait combien de temps
que vous savez déjà un petit moment
vous suivez l'actualité vous et vous
comptez un mal en soi peut-être y
retourner bientôt et messieurs wintacq
cette fin entre l'administration
peut-être vous vous verrez contre n'ont
pas vraiment on verra on verra
puisque vous savez j'ai aussi travaillé
avec l'administration clinton dont
conviera d'action parce que vous avez
fait souvent la navette entre la
martinique et les états unis faut le
rappeler demande que ce sera encore le
cas dans quelques années ce sera
probablement le cas là bas qu'on vient
de dire comment vous pouvez justement
les états unis sous la présidence de joe
biden et la vice-présidence de kamala
harris et toute l'administration
merci mr bûcher bonne journée à toutes
et à tous nous retrouver jimmy damas